[Music]
thank you
the wisdom for life where we sit through
philosophy to find practical advice that
you can use in your everyday life hi I'm
Dan Hayes I'm joined by my co-host Dr
Greg Sadler and today we're talking
about stoic insights from seneca's book
on anger and you know there's a lot to
say about this great work of stoic
philosophy I should say that one of the
reasons why I pitched this to Dan in the
first place was because I was recently
teaching this to my students in my anger
and Justice class that I'm teaching once
again this semester at Marquette
University and so I thought we would
double dip a little bit and talk about
something that that I was already doing
some some work on but it's it's also a
text that Dan is very familiar with
right so
yeah um but like how dare you Greg
this is my anger ah that sucks that's
pretty anemic anger I think that's yeah
I I'm not sure Sonic would actually call
that anger so you guys there's
definitely not a boiling of the spirit
you have to dial it up a bit yeah turn
it up to 11.
why why this book in the first place
right
um I mean Dan and I both know that it's
a great work of what we could call moral
psychology and ethics and philosophy of
the emotions but maybe not everybody is
quite as familiar with it so we'll give
you a little rundown on that and then
talk about stoicism just in case anybody
doesn't quite know what that is and then
we'll we'll start getting into the real
meat so actually before we do that
though do you want to talk about how you
ran into this book and I'll say how I
did as well
um I guess
is definitely not the first thing that I
ran into within stoicism I did find it
before or after I started getting into
it
um but uh it was definitely useful
insights because uh you know I used to
be rather angry
um yeah me too boy
um and socialism in general and this
specifically really enumerates all the
potential reasons that you know someone
would give that anger is a good or
should be used and as a tool and just
kind of shatters them
um so it's uh not only that you know
it's going to give you a whole bunch of
insight too
um ways in which you can either uh deal
with the anger as it arises or to
um prevent it from happening in the
first place yeah you know this is
actually the first work of Seneca that I
myself read and kind of similar reasons
although I wasn't getting into I got
into stoicism through Epictetus and I
didn't really pay much attention to
Seneca but then I started getting really
interested in using uh resources from
philosophy to work on my own anger which
was out of control for quite a long time
and I you know I knew that Seneca had a
book on it so that I started reading
that and that was my introduction to
seneca's works as a whole
um you know I think a lot of people read
his moral letters or they're sometimes
called letters from Achilles or ethical
letters there's a whole bunch of
different titles for it but this was the
first one for me and and like you said
it's got so much packed into it so let's
let's talk about the book this is one of
many many treatises on Anger from the
ancient world where they saw it as a
huge problem most of these have been
lost we actually get a reference to one
of them by this guy Jerome who is an
Aristotelian or hirominus and we don't
we don't have anything of his his work
but there were there were quite a few of
these circulating around and Seneca has
survived and it it's a systematic
analysis of Anger from a stoic
perspective and like like Dan was just
saying it's it's got some critical
engagement with alternate alternate
different views on on anger that the
stoics considered wrong I think that is
actually one of the strong points of the
work is it'll say people say x here's
why X is wrong-headed all right yeah so
Seneca was a ancient author he was a
stoic himself he unfortunately was the
advisor to the emperor Nero tried to
retire from that you know it's sort of
like that old line of you know I keep
trying to get out of the game but they
pulled me back in and Nero pulled him
back in to have him killed and so that's
that's not great but he wrote a number
of different Works about stoic
philosophy and one of the cool things I
like about Seneca is he doesn't just
present the stoic position he tells you
all about everybody else's positions and
if there's anything good in it from his
point of view he'll he'll adopt it even
the epicureans who the stoics at least
some of them viewed as like their mortal
enemies you know Seneca is like they got
something useful to contribute I'll take
it on right yeah he refers to wisdom as
our you know Common Heritage that yeah
regardless from which school it arises
um we should be sharing that which is
kind of interesting in reference to like
our current modern
um technology that like there's an idea
that uh uh information wants to be free
and this is from I believe the hacker
Manifesto okay
um you know kind of an extension of this
like yeah why are all these academic
papers behind pay walls especially with
many of them being you know funded by uh
government grants then yeah why is this
not our common Heritage our common
knowledge but
um that's the difference from the point
that you know he's uh he's happy to dip
his toe wherever he can find something
good and useful to bring out well I'm
gonna piggyback on that digression and
actually suggest that because I've been
thinking about this for quite a while
because of my own students maybe we
should do an episode on the ethics of
we'll just call it the ethics of piracy
um you know
Journal articles other other white
papers things like that that people want
us to pay lots and lots of money for
that like you said somebody else has
done the free labor for it or the
government's even like ponyed up should
we feel bad if we get something off of
one of these sites and then you know use
it for some some common good maybe not
but that's a topic for another day I
think right yeah
but that could be interesting so so what
should we say about stoicism sort of a
thumbnail sketch just for anybody who
doesn't already have some awareness of
it I mean I think a lot of people know
the term but they associate it with the
stiff upper lip kind of disposition
rather than the actual philosophy
right and so you know one of the things
we're going to actually talk about later
on is it's kind of like the you know
we'll stuff down your emotions and the
the app the stoics are you know they're
like you should be so in tune with your
emotions that you know why they're
happening and don't let them carry you
off with you
um so there's not a a trying to suppress
the emotions but to understand why they
arise in the first place
um but specifically there's a couple of
things that are um ideas within stoses
and that are going to be very useful for
understanding what he's talking about
here
uh the two that I I'm bringing up are
indifference in the dichotomy of control
okay
so how do the indifference well what are
the indifference first of all for our
audience
so the indifference are on there are
things that are good and things are bad
and everything else is no different
um and so the things that are actually
good or bad are things that are
completely one within one's own control
those are um the things that you are
drawn to the things that you are averse
to your actions and your opinions and
your judgments or I guess technically
it's your movement towards actions
because actions can be hindered yeah
yeah
um and so this leaves the vast majority
of our wife to indifference like your
house is in a different your the money
in your bank account is indifferent your
job is indifferent your uh relationships
are technically indifference but how you
use them or how you interact with these
people these are things that it can
actually be classified as good or bad
okay well that's that's good that you
clarified that because I think a lot of
people are going to hear that and
they're like wait a second my money
doesn't matter at all is that what
you're saying and they're not they're
the stoics aren't saying yeah just throw
it all away it's no it's no good you
don't need it at all
they're just saying that you know uh
money as was all these other things I
just said can be used for either good or
bad ends but it's the things themselves
do not carry the value with them
do you think that the word neutral works
well for as a synonym maybe for for
indifference or not uh yeah I think so
that's a fairly and it's a more common
word yeah
yeah um and then the second one here is
the dichotomy of control
and so we now we have this idea of what
is a neutral thing or an indifferent and
the things that we should be worried
about are not these indifference but our
actions maybe in reference to these
things especially other people and so
most of the things that people get angry
at are going to be indifference
um and the the scent when these Central
ideas of socialism is that you should be
focusing on what you can control
indifference you can't control so focus
on the things and be don't be disturbed
by those things that are not
yeah I was just thinking like Epictetus
and he talks about being hindered right
so we can be hindered in things that are
externals outside of our control and
difference
and we can't be hindered in our own
inner character or or will however you
want to express it all that stuff that's
up to us and when we do get like
hindered or impeded or somebody gets in
our way or interferes with us we get
ticked off quite often because we we
treat that as if it's like somehow a big
big you know action against us and but
really nobody can according to the
stoics nobody can actually harm us in
the very center of our being
so knowing that can can help people out
I think quite a bit we should we should
talk about the stoic view on anger and
the emotions
um you know the stoics think that all of
our emotions and they're not you totally
unique in this but they think that our
emotions aren't just feelings or like
stimulus response there's a cognitive
content there meaning that we were
thinking something as well as feeling
something so you know when we're
thinking angrily we think things like I
want to get that SOB or can you believe
what they what the crap that they just
pulled you know or we think all sorts of
other things as as well and the stoics
think that anger is always bad it's
never productive it's never helpful it's
always something that is negative
so it can't really be used or harnessed
for for good it's not you could say
anger is not an indifferent itself right
feeling angry is always on the bad side
because it is based upon an incorrect
judgment and a judgment in our control
yeah so I mean all the emotions are
based on judgments and we can get them
right or we can get them wrong and
you're right one one of the things we
could say from the stoic perspective is
any time that you're angry you've got
something wrong
you might have some things right you
know maybe you're mad because somebody
deliberately I don't know you're walking
down the street with your you're reading
your stoic books and somebody knocks
them out of your hands and says
something mean to you and they do it
deliberately to you right and all those
are you know the books did fall that's a
fact
um maybe their motive they they actually
like it's on their t-shirt they say I'm
going to get Dan Hayes you know and
knock the books out of his hand right
they they spent the time ahead of time
to do that you know that they they're
deliberately doing that but the Judgment
that we should retaliate and that this
is the right thing to do that's that's
where we're going wrong right
and
so this doesn't
um say that like
there isn't a response that we should
totally ignore this yeah yeah but to
what is the way that one should make a
decision and has motivate yourself
towards an action and the Stokes and
especially Seneca here says that anger
should never be the basis for your
movement towards a retaliatory action
that uh yeah there might be a need to
um stop a person from like this doing
these things because this is definitely
going to be detrimental to you know
myself individually but also kind of
generally in society people are going
around like just you know causing
General chaos yeah and so how do we
respond to this how do we correct these
uh particular things as well as
um do this without
um wanting to cause pain because that's
one of the main things that we use
usually is like kind of this eye for an
eye I want to have Revenge yeah part of
the reason why our justice system
doesn't allow that there's a an
intermediary between the two of them
because
victims of crimes usually feel
um anger and want retribution
um and that actually doesn't result in a
really good Society yeah it's kind of
indiscriminate
um Seneca points that out in the work
that you're a better judge if you you
know you may have to inflict punishment
even capital punishment but you can do
it without being angry anger doesn't
have to be the motivating
Force
um
now you know the the stoics also saw
anger as interfering with good things so
human beings are rational creatures
which means not just that we can
calculate and think you know and make
arguments but also that we should feel
affection towards other people and be
gentle with them and you know provide
them with assistance and so anger
oftentimes gets in the way of that right
it'll cut us off from what we call it
our
full Human Nature
right to we are social creatures
and one of the main things that doesn't
quite get brought up a lot especially
early on when people like you're just
getting into solar system is that it's
an incredibly pro-social right
and that uh you know Marcus really has a
wine you know that we should on be
working together like two hands two feet
the two eyes the upper and lower row of
teeth too
um to spite or to cause damage to
another is to cause damage to myself and
so there's this this constant like idea
that was like we are part of this you
know it's you know cosmopolitism that we
are all part of the single policy or
group of people
um and that's uh working against each
other is actually working against
yourself and uh yeah one of these these
um
qualities if you want to go to the um
like the core stoic virtues on a
genderness affection and mutual
assistance I believe this is under
um justice justice yeah yeah you know
and anger is often isolating even if we
get angry altogether with a group of
people
you know you think about like online
mobs right where people are all together
and they they're kind of reinforcing
each other and saying awful things to
somebody in Twitter Facebook or pick
whatever else you want
there's still kind of they've got
blinders on they're isolated from the
rest of everybody else and they there's
this tendency to easily think that what
you're doing is a-okay
without looking carefully at you know
whether you are crossing all sorts of
lines
so yeah and you know go ahead a quick
digression because it just it made me
think of you know nowadays especially
within our own culture of like what is
it to be what are the qualities that are
um put up
as exemplified of men
and you mean masculinity right what is
yeah what is what does our Western
United States version of masculinity
um put up on a pedestal
um and what are the things that if you
are them would be considered that you're
not that you're more feminine or
something or something to be derided and
gentleness affection and mutual
assistance are all things that would
potentially be put into you know this
more feminine if you're doing them
you're not nearly as masculine as you
should be yeah and it's interesting too
because the the people who want to like
talk about alpha males and I I always
joke around that anybody who worries
about whether they're an alpha or a beta
they're definitely a beta you know
anybody who like calls himself an alpha
male definitely a beta because real
alpha males wouldn't do that sort of
thing you know but it's interesting when
when a man and it takes strength to to
actually
deal with your anger be gentle be
vulnerable to others try to work things
out that will piss off a lot of other
guys they'll be like what can you
believe the crap that he's doing you
know and you'll be like buddy it's none
of your business why are you so upset
about that why are you such a snowflake
you know you tough guy uh you're you're
got this tough exterior but you really
like marshmallow on the inside if that
gets to you you know and I I think that
you know the stoics could
quite easily make sense of that
right and and a lot of it is what is a
big exemplified you know emotional state
is anger yeah um
and
um but to to finish like the these
things Seneca is making an argument that
these are all aspects that a full human
should have and that's kind of at a
direct the pro-social opposition yeah
gentleness affection Mutual assistance
are all part of justice for being a full
virtuous human being yeah and you know
there were a lot of people in seneca's
own time he mostly targets the
aristotelians but there were others as
well who were saying that anger is
something Noble or necessary or natural
or helpful or useful if you want to get
things done if you want you know he's
got some extreme cases where somebody's
like well what if somebody's killing
your father raping your mother and
Seneca is like
nobody says you can't stop them but you
don't actually have to get angry in
order to do that as a matter of fact you
might be better off not being angry so
you can you can you know approach things
in a a more careful Manner and and put
an end to this this wickedness that's
taking place you know right
another thing that the stoics do well
stanica at least brings out I mean I
don't know that all the stoics believe
this but
um Seneca says anger is the worst of all
the the bad emotions or the vices that
we can fall into and he provides you
with a whole bunch of interesting
arguments and I say interesting because
I don't consider all of them to be great
arguments but they are interesting to
look at and I don't know maybe there is
something to that he does he does point
out that anger has this tendency to
morph into something that's worse than
anger which he calls uh brutality or
it's a fairytos in Latin so you could
like ferality right being like a rabid
animal or cruelty uh where a person you
know the angry person is is upset and is
is being moved by this this passion the
cruel person actually just Delights in
hurting other people you know they'll
smile while they're doing it whereas
they angry person their face is all
clenched up and stuff like that you know
and he's he knows a lot of Roman people
who are quite cruel so including Nero
yeah yeah
ah
so you know the the
Stokes are like the word for these
emotions these negative emotions or Pate
um which is what we eventually get uh
pathological right from and so these
these things are things that are
negative to the point where they um can
kind of control and take over us and so
um
what is it taking over but our reason so
um anything that can be used
yeah but with anger can be done using
reason
um and it's likely to be more effective
we should say something this is a little
bit of a technical aspect of stoicism
it's it's what we call philosophical
anthropology like how how is the psyche
or the personality divided up and you
know some
people in ancient time thought there
were like maybe two main parts like a
rational or an irrational part or maybe
the irrational part has a couple
different parts the stoics thought there
was one main thing that they called the
ruling part which was also the rational
part the part that we choose things with
and it's not just rational that's also
where we feel these emotions and so the
emotion there's sort of like there's
only limited space right so the more
that anger is there the less that reason
can be operative and and vice versa you
know so that's something worth keeping
in mind especially as we go on and and
we should talk we should probably move
ahead instead of talking about the we're
going to talk about definitions we'll
skip over that but
um you've got this seneca's Litany of
reasons anger is not a virtue and I like
that term litany like you're just
rattling them off so do you want to run
through them and rattle them off like
that sure
um so on anger has cause great harm to
mankind if anger is more powerful than
reason the only way to control it is to
set against it more powerful Vice such
as fear wherefore reason is in the
position of
fat flying to the aid of vices How Could
you
um anger does not benefit you in war you
want your attacks to be thought out and
orderly anger is poor own to rashness
anger is also not a weapon because it
cannot be put down at will
good qualities become better the
stronger they are anger is not good in
large quantities reductio at absurdum it
cannot be a good quality anger is a
terrible judge and is inconsistent Hasty
and can invent crimes where none exist
anger affects those of weak Minds anger
results in misery is better to endure
hardship than to give into anger anger
leads one to inhuman acts anger becomes
addictive anger can ruin and tear apart
whole Nations anger can lead one to act
without thought some even become angry
with inadequate objects yeah so this
this last one um you know he uses the um
the
a reference to oh who's the uh
so you he's a a king and he's he's angry
that the the the waters are blocking him
from doing the attack that he wants so
he goes out he starts uh it's one of his
Persian kings that was it serious with
Xerxes I think it's Xerxes right uh no
it's oh it starts with the c I want to
say Can basis he was another one of the
Persian kings he was the one who who
attacked Egypt
um but yeah there's all sorts of
examples of of people getting angry with
inanimate objects and this is actually a
common place of the literature on anger
you see this like later in the Christian
monastic literature John Cassian talks
about the monk who goes out into the
desert because he's going to get away
from all these bastards who are ticking
him off right and he says if you don't
handle your anger you're bringing it
with you out to the desert you're going
to get angry at your sleeping mat for
not rolling upright you're gonna get
angry at your pen for not writing
correctly you'll get angry at the wind
for blowing on you or not blowing yeah
people and you know and Seneca in
analyzing that he says how stupid is
that you know getting angry at a person
kind of makes sense because a person can
like deliberately screw with you right
there's an intention an agency there
however you know mistaken but in an
inanimate object doesn't care it doesn't
have any care it doesn't care or not
care because it's not something that can
do that sort of sort of mental act you
could say it has no intentionality yeah
um and and I found my notes it's Osiris
that's okay
um and then it gives another example of
on
uh Julius Caesar on destroying a villa
because his mother was once in prison
there you know like you're you're
attacking or the idea is like um do you
ever get angry at a tornado no one gets
angry at the tornado they know it at
least nowadays
um yeah it's an a natural disaster
um
I mean
probably as somebody who gets angry at
the tornado I'm guessing
but in general those of us don't get
angry at the tornado you know like it
has no intention you know what we do get
angry at though that's inanimate objects
and this this could be like we could
talk about this for days
our technology right oh yeah uh you you
turn on your phone and you pull up an
amp and the app like closes Itself by
itself and you're like you SOB what are
you doing there right and it's just
um you know it's it's programs it's
there's nothing deliberate about it and
you don't and is it funny too because
Seneca says well you know some people
might actually say it's the work person
who should have done a better job the
artifex and we could be angry at them
right so you're I don't know your phone
breaks you're like damn Apple you know
but most of us don't do that most of us
get mad at the phone or at the car
instead of the you know Subaru motor
company or you know the pagination isn't
right in the book we don't get mad at
like University of Chicago press we get
mad at the book itself and Sonic
actually talks about people like ripping
Pages out of books because something is
written wrongly in in the book so yeah
there's this concept always
was so alien to me like you see like
movies or what the the destroying things
because you're angry I'm like
I grew up in you watched movie sound
like the first one that comes to mind is
on Citizen Kane there's this big scene
where he like destroys an entire room
um and it's like this Trope but like I
never got so angry that I was like I
have to destroy something I might have
like punched a pillow once or twice but
like I knew that was going to be able to
take the brunt of it I [__] crap off my
desk
I remember doing that yeah you know uh
and I remember as a kid
um one way that I would not effectively
deal with my anger we had a uh an ax and
we used it for splitting wood and stuff
like that and we we had a backyard that
went out into a forest and so my my mom
would say when you're angry go out there
and chop down a tree you know there's
plenty of trees and we can use the wood
you know or you can put it into a
bonfire whatever you want to do just go
out there and chop down a tree and so
I'd go out there you know I was mad
about something and I'd hack at that
tree for a while it wasn't a great
Woodsman at first so you know it was
very effective for keeping me busy
because it would take a long time to
chop the trees down and I noticed I
didn't actually feel any better after I
did all that
you know interesting yeah
well we should we should move on
um we we do want to get to a whole bunch
of practices so maybe we'll skip over
the discussion about like the different
movements and emotion and we'll save the
like do we disagree with the stoics for
maybe the end what do you think
you really want to go through those
quickly okay so I guess just to get us
there because like one of the things
that you don't like is this idea of
um how the emotions occur and then you
know he says that he doesn't
um think that once you've latched onto
the emotion that you can stop it yeah
right
um so and I think he's a little
inconsistent in that too with so uh the
quick idea of what a stoic emotion is
you've got a um an impression a place
for reflection and then you will Center
descent to the emotion so the impression
is like you have something that would
originally you know someone uh yelled
and called you dumb or something yeah or
something worse so it doesn't matter um
but that was that that's the initial
moment you automatically have a response
from your unconscious brain it goes bam
you should be angry yeah and if and if
you don't reflect on that you're like
yup it should be time to be angry
um says like there's a plan in there
that you should be reflecting on these
things on to then refer you know run
through that and maybe step back from it
and not only do they think that you
should reflect on it you you do reflect
on it you just don't realize that that's
happening
so that's this juncture so the first
part is what what they often call A
pre-emotion or a proto-passion not
exactly seneca's term but it's good
enough and then the third part is you
are now Angry and you're out of control
you're you're acting on that and in
between is this space which you know
could be like a second but could also be
like minutes long
and you have the opportunity to exercise
judgment to Ascent or like you said
dissent to not buy into something and
it's interesting because Seneca also
uses two other important words there one
of them is reason you can think about
this at that point although it's it's
maybe tough and then he even uses the
word will voluntas in Latin you choose
whether you go along with this thing
that's pushing you right so you're not
like choosing in a vacuum somebody has
called you I don't know you know hey
a-hole you know and you're like are you
talking to me and they're like yeah I'm
definitely talking to you buddy now
you're starting to get riled up right
and part of what you're choosing to do
is to buy into all these other
assumptions and judgments like hey I
shouldn't have to put up with that crap
I should go punch that guy in the nose
that's the way to handle this you know
or flip them off or whatever else it's
going to be
so you know I I kind of I think that I'm
a whole this makes sense the thing that
I just don't buy is that once we've like
crossed the threshold from the second
part to the third part that now we're
totally out of control and there's
nothing we can do Seneca seems a bit
more fatalistic about that than some of
the other stoics like Epictetus who
thinks that you can while you're angry
still reason with yourself
or somebody else who's angry you can
reason with them it's just real real
hard you know
so I I think I kind of lean more towards
Epictetus than Seneca on this but I
think it's useful for a lot of a lot of
people to you know it's useful as a
practice because you can be like okay
this is my moment of opportunity let's
not screw it up I'm starting to slide
into anger if I don't uh get a hold of
it right now it's gonna take me away
with it that right that might be very
helpful right
right so how do we stem these in the
beginning is going to be one of the big
things we're going to go um is there
another one of these um disagreements
that you would really want to bring up
um
well yeah and and it's connected to this
like third stage of things so Seneca
tells us that anger if you're actually
able to control it it's not really anger
and I I think that's just wrong you know
I think you can be pretty angry and
have some measure of control it just
takes a lot of work and he also he's got
these things and he's not completely
consistent on this where he says what
the animals feel is not really anger
it's only human beings who feel it I
just don't buy that you know I think
that that we're closer to the other
animals maybe they don't get angry about
exactly the same stuff that we do I mean
you can call them names and they're not
it's not really going to bother them the
way it bothers us but take away a dog's
food while they're eating
they'll get angry or you Hank their tail
you know uh yeah
yeah or even like the you know throw
fake them out with the ball you throw
the ball but you don't really throw it
after a while they'll get ticked off at
you and they might even bite you for
that and I think it really comes down to
like their idea of you know Stoke
physics which is like everything like
okay and and uh specifically that what's
what makes humans different from the
rest of the animals in the world is that
we have this little uh piece of logos
you know and so it's very dichotomous
either you have it or you don't yeah and
so if you have it then you can actually
have anger because you are able to think
about it I guess
um from
um modern science I I I'm very suspect
of most of the the stoic physics and
yeah as we see there are many many uh
creatures and animals
um that have really quite high
intelligence and it's a spectrum of like
you know from very low intelligence to
you know also very high intelligence
there are a number a couple of other
species you know dogs and um dolphins
and uh octopi and the great apes
and Ravens yeah
um that are quite intelligent and they
might not have the exact same experience
but there's a a close enough analogy
that there's definitely like an angry
state that I could see them being in
yeah well let's let's talk about some of
the practice I mean unless
yeah quickly we kind of brought it up a
little bit when you're talking about
you're going out to on uh cut down the
trees cut the cut down the trees yeah on
that he says that um you know if you're
feeling angry
um which is also kind of counter to this
idea that you can like stop it you can
use it reasonable cameras like you're
feeling angry you're now Angry well
don't show it physically outwardly just
kind of like stew on it sit on it and I
guess I I disagree with him here's like
you know it's
there are a number of techniques to
potentially help in there some might
work for some people and some work for
others yeah on them so like for example
like I knew that one of my coping
techniques when I was younger was still
like I just need to go for a walk and so
I would for like you know a 20 minute
walk to get away from things to move
myself away from the thing that was
causing me anger in the first place of
the person
um and if I couldn't do that it made
things worse for me
did it help you to go on the walk oh
yeah absolutely
you know there's they use that in a lot
of Anger Management stuff and I think
one of the things that often gets left
out of that
is if you go on the walk you have to
like pay attention to where you're
walking or you know look at the nature
or you can't just keep thinking about
why you're ticked off because then you
just come back from the walk still
ticked off right you can't ruminate you
might say and I think a lot of people
leave that out
yeah the rumination gets you
um yeah so practice and insight yeah
what's what are what are your favorite
ones from
seneca's on anger there's there's so
many of them we're not going to be able
to get too many
um
I guess
I guess I'll grab um one about
um
oh I guess associated with good tempered
people okay that's a good one yeah and
so uh we copy the habits of those people
from around us yeah there's that that
line of your the average of the five
closest people that you know on and
um that we uh you we are what we
repeatedly do and we tend to do the
things that our friends do and so you
know for example
um
when I was a kid I was I was fairly
straight laced but there's a couple of
times where I got into trouble and so
like one point in time
um you know there's uh the the valve
caps for uh cars right okay and and some
are metal they're nice and shiny and so
like when I was in elementary school a
couple of the the kids I knew were all
into like stealing these little things
not not to like you know
empty the the tires or anything just to
have these little metal yeah uh caps
um I did that until like I was doing it
and someone noticed that there's a kid
screwing out there's car it came out and
yelled at me and I was like oh no with
that
we we had people in high school who used
to steal hood ornaments but not just any
it would have to be a like you know
Cadillacs or Dodge Rams or you know if
they could find a Porsche they would
definitely steal that you know so I
think I think there's that's pretty
common that kind of behavior but you're
right if you spend a lot of time around
people who manage their anger poorly
even if you're like practicing
some restraint you're probably going to
be affected by them sooner or later and
and if you're unfortunate enough to come
from say a family where anger has been
handled poorly you're probably behind
everybody else right do you have certain
tools that you've been taught on how to
deal with problems and if anger is the
one that is the right one is
demonstrated to you then you're going to
you know fit that into oh I'm in this
situation I should be angry there's like
as it reminds me of um you know you see
a little kid
um and they they're learning to walk and
they fall down and then they look up at
you
to see how that they should respond all
right right and so if you are super
concerned they get concerned they start
crying and you're like oh yeah that's
good you get right back up they're like
yes yes we should do that and uh they're
they're mirroring you
um
yeah I mean it also reminds me of a
point that you made a bit earlier about
uh masculinity within our society or and
it could even be expanded not to
masculinity but just to be like being
like viewed as an uh you know a tough
person or as assertive right because I
think I think a lot of women get in on
this as well
um particularly in certain Fields so
you know a lot of people use anger as a
substitute for feeling and dealing with
other emotions
particularly negative ones like grief or
fear or Envy or
um sadness or yeah despair I think a lot
of people would much rather feel angry
because anger feels like it's getting
something done even if it isn't right
and these other emotions you feel them
you feel kind of out of control like uh
you don't really get to decide things
anger has this illusion of control and
especially if you're coming from like a
culture or a group where that is being
rewarded right then it's it's really
easy to fall into that and it becomes
almost like a habit instead of feeling
pain you feel anger instead of feeling
uh sadness you feel anger right
you might even feel anger afterwards
when you normally would feel sad about
like having lost your temper you get mad
at other people for having made you lose
your temper
no we're incredible at you know pattern
recognition and we're going to you know
match the patterns of the things that we
observe
yeah that's that's a good way to put it
um so what's one of your practices or
insights well you know I think coming
back to this this thing about
um assertiveness and masculinity Seneca
spends a lot of time
trying to combat this idea that anger is
something either Noble or Brave or to
use another term that we don't use all
that much magnanimous or great sold you
know being being kind of a high-minded
person
and he you know he considers arguments
that people put forward it was common at
the time to talk about the scythians and
the Germans as being free peoples who
have this you know anger irascible
element in them and look at how cool
they are you know there's there's kind
of a a weird you know worship of the
Barbarian and he says this is a you
don't want to emulate them look at their
societies they're all messed up you know
they can't govern themselves they can't
live in an orderly way
um their bravery doesn't really work out
that that great it turns into
recklessness they seem like really great
Fighters but we Romans kick their Bots
because they don't have organization in
order and they don't because they're you
know allowing themselves to be too riled
up and then
right after that he talks about you know
animals that we uh we look at that and
we're like oh you know look at those
tough animals look at a lion you know
and he's like why the hell would you
want to imitate a lion you know there's
so many better animals for you to to
imitate and what it's better the more
ferocious it is so the most ferocious
lion that eats all the other Lions even
is that what you think is a good thing
and I I think there's there's something
to that you know uh even Lions you know
who can be pretty tough you know and a
lot of lions die at the hands of other
Lions
um they also display affection towards
each other and they're young and you
know they spend a lot of time actually
just lying around too and then he he
talks about angry people one of the
other things that people are often
inclined to believe in in his society
and ours angry people are more
straightforward they tell you what they
think you know there there's no guile
about them and he says well okay they're
they're better by comparison to crafty
people who conceal everything but this
is not the same thing as like being on
the up and up this is just being
uncontrolled and in cautious and rash
you know they'll say stupid things that
they shouldn't say because they're
they're angry they're not really like
honest they're just unable to control
themselves and then you know he talks
about like greatness of Soul this this
was very important for the Ancients and
I think it is for us too
we don't conceptualize it enough but
being able to be like independent of of
what's Happening
he says and this is a quote from him
there's no more certain proof of
greatness than remaining unprovoked by
whatever happens the lofty mind is ever
peaceful firmly moored in its tranquil
Anchorage suppressing all of anger's
components controlled and orderly and I
think there's something to that you know
you get into like
you get into a situation where people
are trying to
get you going
being able to not get provoked by them
that is a you getting to remain in
control being above them in a certain
way especially if they're if they're
doing it specifically because they want
to get a reaction out of you and and
then they get upset when they don't get
that right they're like I can't believe
that you you didn't respond to that
you'd be like I don't care what you
think buddy you know
there's a a common litany on or a
refrain on the internet you mad bro
they're trying to get a rise out of you
that's right yeah and they're they're
trying to push your buttons
I will say too as a motive to a bit of
digression it's amazing on the internet
to me how many people who I think are
probably emotionally immature themselves
will attribute you saying no you got
that wrong because people will put
comments on all sorts of videos that I
do and and I'll say no no you got you
got Hagel wrong there you got nature
wrong there and one of their reactions
is I don't know why you're getting angry
about this and I'll be like what in what
I said makes you think that I'm angry
how are how is it you that you're
reading this in and projecting that you
know
um I actually had somebody today who who
said something kind of boneheaded and I
corrected him about it and he wrote me
an email and it was you know he was you
know apologizing for antagonizing me and
I was like he didn't antagonize me where
are you getting this from you know
you're projecting and the answer is
they're treating you as if you're like
them they would get angry if somebody
said something wrong on the internet
right so they think that that's you you
know I think there's a lot about the
projector yeah yeah that that that
project you know entirely and I think
the internet is probably worse than that
maybe
yeah and the other thing that came out
here as a slight digression is this
honesty that comes with anger that this
idea and the first thing that came to
mind was on the
um Brett Kavanaugh you know Supreme
Court Justice who when he was in his
confirmation hearing you mean yeah and
he um at one point got very very angry
yeah this is like I that these
accusations are are baseless and thus
uses anger to try to instill an idea of
honesty uh if he's honest or not it
should not be defined by his anger and
as you said it should be more uh you
know
him being in cautious or foolish than
honest
you know on that point too
a lot of times people will say things
that at the time they feel are true but
then later on they look at them and I
can't believe I said that to my partner
my co-worker my boss pick whoever it's
going to be my child you know so anger
doesn't necessarily produce honesty it
it makes you more liable to say what it
is on your mind which could be
completely false and wrong and
uncharitable you know right makes you
rash yeah yeah so another thing another
Insight is you know to cut out those
things that aggravate you
um and so you know the the stoics were
are
all about this idea of like trying to
increase your ability to deal with these
externals
um in a more rational way but they also
realize that people aren't going to be
able to just turn a switch and change
their a way that they interact with
things and so until you have progressed
enough that these things are not going
to disturb you anymore you need to
figure out a way to remove these things
from your cell so that you're not
constantly being triggered into an angry
State and so you know cut out things
that aggravate you remove yourself from
things that tend to make you angry he
puts out as example Law Courts and
politics
um and and politics is definitely a
through line to our current world yeah I
mean think about how it used to be back
in the day right let's think about
seneca's day before there's even like
newspapers or stuff like that in order
to find out what's going to happen
politically you you kind of have to be
there or you got to know somebody who
can tell you the Senate today did this
and this and so and so said this right
otherwise you don't have a clue what's
happening right and you're probably
better off not knowing it whereas at we
at the touch of our fingertips have like
access to thousands of potentially anger
producing media sources some of which
are that's their entire business model
right so here's some of my my little um
anger Skinner boxes beeping at me all
the time
yeah true true yeah and you know he he
uh he suggests there may be some fields
of study that we should avoid if if
we're prone to getting too frustrated
you know uh you know let's say you're
not good at music right and somebody's
like yeah you should learn to play the
guitar and you're like okay fine I'll
get myself a teach myself guitar book
and there'll be tutorials and you just
can't get your fingers to work right
you're going to get pissed off and maybe
you'll even smash the guitar you know
right like yeah especially if you've got
a smaller hands you can't actually wrap
your fingers all the way around the
nodes are too big there you go so uh and
so yeah he says like know where your
talents lie and uh don't try to excel at
things that you know that you're not
gonna excel at you know you might want
to dabble or yeah well that's an
interesting one because in our current
existence right there's way too many
opportunities for you to compare
yourself off against super talented
people because you can see them on
YouTube right and then you feel like
crap about yourself and then now you get
angry
but
it's okay was it uh
um sucking at something his first step
of being sort of good at something true
yeah yeah and you should never be um the
only person that you should compare to
yourself is the person you were
yesterday so uh or another quote on uh
comparison is a thief of Happiness oh
that's good where does that one come
from I'm not sure
I like that one yeah yeah because with
comparison very often will come envy and
jealousy and you know a wish to pull
others down to your level you know none
of those things are helpful for us
so
we probably have enough time to talk
about one more yeah how about you tell
me yeah so I like this one that he talks
about really late in book two and you
could call it
um he doesn't call it this but I think
we could call it why why aren't you
thinking about this you're so stupid you
know he says we get upset not just
because we think we're wrong but because
we think we're we've been unfairly
wronged and so we have this idea this is
like a judgment or an assumption we
shouldn't have suffered these things or
these things are unexpected we feel that
things that are contrary to our
expectations are as he puts it
inappropriate meaning they they're
unsuited to how things are
and we're often super unrealistic about
how things go so he he talks about
things that happen at home I mean if you
have an apartment or a house or a dorm
room things break down that's that's the
natural way things go you know you buy
something it's not going to stay
pristine forever just like when you buy
a car right you take that car off the
lot it's already losing value and as
soon as you take it off the lot things
start to like something goes wrong a
bird craps on your window you know the
wipers don't work quite the way they're
supposed to you start hearing a little
noise if you let that sort of thing get
to you rather than saying well this is
this is what happens with with things
you're going to be really upset and then
he talks about enemies and he says our
enemies trying to harm us
shouldn't we expect that I mean if
people don't like us if people have it
in for us
why in the hell would we think that
they're not going to screw with us you
know he he says we we judge that we
should be undisturbed even by our
enemies and then he says how is it
strange if bad Deeds proceed from bad
people you know and and you know there's
bad people there's good people there's a
lot of people in between people are
going to let us down you know not
everybody is going to be into the things
that we're into
um people are going to make dumb
mistakes here and there and then not not
you know admit them this is not
unexpected this is like if you're
realistic about human beings and your
experiences then you should kind of be
okay with that sort of stuff and so he
says well what makes us so inclined to
anger ignorance you know maybe not
knowing how things go or arrogance
thinking that somehow we should our
experience should be different than
everybody else's so I mean think about
when you go to a restaurant right
all the different things that can go
wrong there you went to the restaurant
last time and the food was so good and
the service was so good and you were
there on a date with this person and it
was so much fun and now you're you're
going back with a friend and you're like
oh we got to go to this really great
place it might have been total chance
that you just walked in you threaded a
needle right the good cook was on on
service that night the best you know
server was on everything was coming
together properly that might not be the
the way things normally go you know or
you know you order something from eat
Street and it comes and it's a little
cold well hell you know what did you
expect it to happen yeah I'm gonna
probably sat there on the counter for 10
minutes and then it's in somebody's car
and then they gotta bring it to your
place so your soup is a little cold put
it in the microwave all right and the
silks are really consistent with this
with other emotions as well like they
talk about you know you you have all
these people that you love in your life
if you're not expecting them to die then
you are not expecting them to be human
yeah and so your sadness on is in part
your misjudgment about the the nature of
humanity exactly yeah so well we're
getting close to the end so do you want
to yeah you wanna bring us out on a
final quote yeah I'm gonna bring us out
on two because uh you know we uh there's
a quote from Seneca talking about how
um we are uh
we suffer more often than imitation and
in imagination reality this is the whole
thing about judgments
um and so that you know we deliberately
make ourselves angry that's my last
little insight on but
now we will leave you with the word
Seneca anger if not restrained is
frequently more hurtful to us than the
injury that provokes it
[Music]
thank you